I can't believe it it's here it's time
hey what up guys my name is Ayana
welcome to this announcement video
because we are about to begin the game
engine series yes you heard me right I
can't believe how long it's been
I'm so excited to say this but that's it
the game engine series is ready and it's
about to start coming out starting next
week cool
that's it I'll see you guys next time oh
no I'm kidding but seriously it's like I
don't know I've been planning this for
like the last two years probably and
I've got this massive plan everything's
ready to go I've just I can't wait to
get started on this it's gonna be a huge
thing for the whole community it's not
gonna be just me kind of working on this
is gonna be everyone it's gonna be
really like in-depth really detailed
there's gonna be heaps of just stuff
that's gonna go into all of the videos
it's just we're gonna build something
really really amazing together and I'm
so excited and I just can't wait to
actually start this thing so I'm like
I'm just so happy right now I can't even
like I don't know what else to say I'm
gonna in this video we're just gonna go
over a little bit about what on earth
the game engine series is for those of
you who are known for those of you who
might be new to my channel but that's
kind of my only plan really for this
series and obviously just to say that
that's it like it's coming it's ready
it's gonna go up like any time it's just
like oh I just can't wait sorry those of
you kind of muted my channel you might
know have noticed that I kind of am like
this channel is kind of like a
programming channel but it's not just
limited to like programming or game
programming or anything like that
essentially it's really just a channel
that revolves around me and my interests
because I love teaching and I love
sharing everything that I learned with
everyone that's always been a passion of
mine and it doesn't make any sense for
me to like teach things that I'm not
interested in all the things that I'm
not currently doing with my life I am at
the moment and follow-up for the last
almost four years now I've been a game
engine developer at EA currently working
in the Frostbite organization on the
mobile engine so that's my life that's
what I do right so I love sharing that
with everyone and to be honest like just
teaching has just always been a huge
passion of mine so what this channel
like it really is is just me kind of
talking about my passions talking about
stuff that interests me whether that be
kind of in vlogs or tutorial videos and
teaching you guys kind of the same thing
that I've learned or just new things
that I've picked up or things that I'm
realizing because I feel the programming
and like you know game engine
development or game development is like
in general has just been like such a
like it's just been it's been over
complicated so so so much and I feel
like with the way that I teach like in a
lot of cases cuz I do private like
sessions as well very limited like
seriously because like I'm so busy but I
do have like five oh five or so students
who I do teach privately one-on-one just
the way that everything clicks for them
when I explain something because I try
and kind of simplify it and just be like
well actually you know if you think
about it you know it's not actually that
difficult like I just love doing that so
much and that's kind of a reflection of
what my channel I guess is about it's
about kind of me teaching my passions
and what the stuff that I'm interested
in in a bit of a sit like in a simple
way and kind of hopefully in that case
helping a lot of you people out because
that's what I love to do now what I want
to say is that my passions don't lie in
game programming at all like I don't
like games I'll say that like it's as
simple as that I don't
I don't play games in my spare time I
did kind of when I was younger when I
was like a kid I guess but like it
basically as soon as I become bit since
I became an adult apart from the
occasional like you know know a game of
something multiplayer with friends like
I don't play games in my spare time at
all I'm just not interested in that I'm
not saying that like I'm against that or
like games or evil or games are bad like
it's a waste of time just for me
personally I I get bored like it's just
not I don't it's not something I enjoy
doing really so of course making games
is also something that I don't
necessarily enjoy doing what I am really
interested in and what I do enjoy a lot
is making game engines and I actually
made a video of log in Germany recently
which I will link up there which is
about you know games versus engines and
kind of deciding what it is that you
want to make and kind of just talking
about the differences it's so bright out
here and just talking about the
differences kind of between you know
what it's like to make a game is what
it's like to make an engine and all that
so check out that video if you want kind
of to meet me to expand a little bit
more about what I'm talking about here
because that's not what this video is
about but the point is like I don't
really like games I really like making
games but what I do love doing is making
engines and I guess this is kind of what
this channel is about and like you know
the simplest boss in the open jail stuff
that I've been teaching over the last
almost two years now has kind of been
specifically geared towards right let's
take all that and let's actually build
an engine now and again like I am gonna
I am titling this the game engine series
right but it's not really necessarily a
going to be a game engine I mean if you
think about what a game engineers and
what specifically I want to be building
is it's just really like kind of a 3d
real-time rendering application that's
what it is right it's a way it's an
engine to make a 3d real-time rendering
application right what I want to be able
to do now and an interactive one at that
as well what I want to be able to do is
make kind of this framework this engine
so that people can construct real-time
interactive 3d applications that is the
idea right with 3d graphics that's the
idea so of course you could apply that
to games absolutely I mean a lot of
people will it's going to be very well
optimized for kind of you know big
scenes and lots of entities and all that
kind of stuff and I'll probably throw in
you know scripting and all of that kind
of game
code because that's not necessarily
applicable to just games either right
what we're going to be building is this
engine that's capable of so much more
than just making games it's just cable
rendering interactive 3d graphics like
that's really cool so I can't wait to
kind of build that with everyone I'll
talk a little bit about what it's going
to include I'm not like we'll have an
overview video where we discuss kind of
the stages of this whole project and
I'll probably like ride kind of on a
whiteboard no totally on a whiteboard
look like a tablet so that you guys can
see and we'll kind of go through
everything step by step I don't want to
really do that now I just off the top of
my head because I'm sure I'll miss
things and I don't want to pull up notes
now we want to kind of sit down in the
studio in the office if you will and
actually go through that but that being
said you know we are going to kind of
break down the project and go through
everything step by step but the idea is
like we're gonna kind of build this
thing together now over me planning this
series and one of the reasons why it
took so long was because it's just such
a massively complicated task building an
engine like this takes years for a whole
team of people right now I'm fortunate
in the fact that I kind of more or less
know what I'm doing because I do have so
many years of experience of actually
making kind of a game engine and being
in a game engine team slide I do know
how to make a game engine I've never
really sat down and made a full kind of
engine from scratch where I would
consider it to the point of like that's
it we can ship applications with this
engine now because it has every slowly
featured right I've never actually done
that in my life I know how everything
works and I've done it all separately in
different modules but to combine it all
into one huge project not something that
I've really done right
and that's something that I've just been
wanting to do so this isn't it this
isn't even just necessarily me being
like alright let's make a series on how
to make a game engine this is me being
like that's it I want to make a game
engine now I want to make my own engine
I want us to make our own engine right
from the ground up
but unlike Sparky which was another
engine that I did make about three years
ago three and a half years ago I think
now right yeah that that was kind of
more or less you know four games
specifically and that was very kind of
like quickly put together because it was
I made it in like the base the base
version of it in like 40 days for for a
game programming competition but like
this is gonna be a like and because of
that it was kind of me typing code and
then explaining somethings along the way
whereas this is gonna be a tutorial like
this is gonna take time it's gonna be
like slow it's gonna be it's gonna
feature me like writing stuff drawing
diagrams for you guys notes all of that
kind of stuff it's gonna be like a
full-course almost right it's not gonna
be just something that I just you know
whip up and kind of improvise on it's
been planned it's like this whole thing
where I'm actually gonna explain
everything and because of that these
videos are gonna be long now that's very
long but there's gonna it's gonna be
very detailed I might not get very far
immediately like it's gonna take a lot
of time to actually build this up and
basically it's almost like like this
engine and I'm sure that it office
obviously my life like I'll probably
scrap this eventually make a new engine
as technology continues to improve and
as I get get smarter and I'd learn new
things as well obviously we'll look
we're all learning new things right but
this is almost like just a almost like a
little life project for me it's just
something that I want to do in my life I
wanna build a game engine you guys gonna
watch me and I'm also going to like work
on it with you guys and I'm also going
to explain everything and teach you what
I'm doing how I'm doing and we're gonna
decide things together so it's gonna be
a really exciting project and I
absolutely can't wait to get this thing
started it's been just I've been wanting
to do this my whole life basically or my
whole kind of YouTube career life and
it's finally happening and I'm
so excited now you guys are gonna come
in in the in the fact that like I am
going to actively work with you guys
this is gonna be a public project on
github it's gonna be completely free of
course it's just gonna be like up on
github you can look through every commit
you can log issues they'll be like issue
tracking we'll have like a project cuz
it's like almost like a Trello board you
can have on github now github project or
whatever it's called we're gonna have
that full thing set up like a
professional game studio I think people
are coming anyway our professional games
your professional team that's gonna be
social so cool
that's gonna be completely free so you
guys gonna interact with that repository
potentially even get collaborators in to
help write the code for this because
again it is gonna be such a big thing
and because it's such a big project that
does kind of require a lot of man-hours
a lot of work obviously I'm gonna have
to cut corners in some places because I
can't just build like unity or unreal by
myself while explaining all of it and
documenting it on video that's that's
that's physically impossible and I'm not
trying to be realistic and they're like
that's what I'm gonna do
it's not like for example with the level
editor and game engine tools that's all
going to be kind of built into the
actual game runtime like using IM GUI
because it's not something that i can
just be like okay I'm gonna make a full
Windows application that's gonna be a
level editor with my own UI framework
with them that's not gonna happen it's
impossible alright like this stuff takes
so much time so there have been like
compromises that I've had to make in
order to actually make this project
realistic and I have thought about a lot
of them and yeah I mean like it's but
it's still gonna be amazing
and I absolutely can't wait and we are
gonna be writing a lot of things from
scratch will be using libraries
obviously and other kind of third-party
vendor comes supplied tools and like
code frameworks or whatever and
the wind isn't bad but overall a lot of
it is gonna be written from scratch from
the ground up which is gonna be really
really really really exciting now if you
want to support this project because I
do need your help this is gonna take a
lot of my time it already has so if you
want to see this project actually kind
of come to life and more of these
episodes to go up I really do need your
support so I do have a patreon patron
Ocampo slash the channel you will get
rewards for helping to support of course
such as early access to like game engine
source code the actual project will be
on github will be public will be free
but you'll get kind of code before it
actually goes up you'll also get
experimental development branches which
is like me already having implemented
certain features before I make the video
about them like and that could be months
before right so you'll kind of see me
write the code as I write myself before
I make videos and all that stuff you can
also hang out with me on like um on
discord we have like a video chat once a
month where we all have all the kind of
partner which is like there's a tier
called partner all of the partners kind
of will kind of hang out in a video chat
we talk about stuff and we've and we've
been talking about the game engine
series for the last year so those guys
actually know a lot about what I'm gonna
it's what I'm saying here now which is
pretty cool because you know that kind
of like I think that's what 20 or so
partners they know like everything which
is really cool when we have like our own
partner and the discord chat and all of
that so you do get a handful of rewards
but most of all you're just allowing me
to kind of maybe work less and and kind
of spend more of my time developing this
game engine series because you'll kind
of be supporting me financially so
that's just such a such an amazing thing
and I'm so grateful for the people who
have made it realistic for me to
actually spend so much of my time on
this so definitely jump on that and
let's see let's see how good how big of
a game engine we can all build together
and how could we how good we can make it
absolutely can't wait I will see you
guys next time
I love all of you goodbye